it's a new year but we've already seen
two deadly crashes on our roads and
several more this past week Madison
Kimbrough joins us tonight after
speaking with drivers about safety on
our Valley streets
[Music]
we are currently in the Southeast Valley
where the first fatal of 2023 occurred
involving a motorcycle and a fixed
object and as you can see candles laid
out for the victim
you see these motorcyclists they're
driving all kind of crazy kind of
dipping in the lanes not really
following the rules Vegas locals sharing
what they've seen out on the valley
roadways at the start of 2023 the first
fatal crash involving a motorcycle
slamming into a light post and brick
wall to a residence near Harmon and lamb
that motorcyclist died on scene then
another crash later in the afternoon
Sunday this time in North Las Vegas as a
small SUV struck another vehicle and two
pedestrians on the sidewalk both
pedestrians were transported to UMC
where one later died those who drive
daily in the valley acknowledging how
scary the roads can be and what they've
experienced these people drive crazy
they don't look in their rear views I
don't like driving at night I've been
hit three times two of them by red light
Runners and one under the influence
so it's a big problem and on Saturday on
the last night of 2022 a woman was hit
while crossing outside of a marked
crosswalk on Boulder Highway her death
marking the 152nd traffic-related
fatality in Metro's jurisdiction for
2022 and two other people were hit and
killed this past Wednesday while on
vacation from New Mexico Christian
William Baxter attempted to cross
against a don't cross pedestrian signal
on 4th Street near the Fremont Street
Experience when they were both hit and
killed that driver arrested and now
facing DUI and hit-and-run charges as
for Metro's traffic statistics for 2022
the total number of hit-and-run cases
have increased by over 35 percent from
2021 and pedestrian fatalities are up by
over seven percent reporting near Harman
and lamb Madison Kimbrough 8 news now
according to Metro's fatal report in
2022 deadly crashes exceeded the number
of crashes in 2021 by one deadly crash
this is the most updated report until
December 23rd the majority of these
caused by DUIs